when this gentleman was last on on this
program was may 15th
so a lot has happened in the world of
nascar in the world in general since the
last time that we spoke to bubba wallace
and i'm not just talking about a very
neat uh
gq profile uh on the driver of the 43
car
uh the from richard petty racing none
other than
uh my friend of the program who i'm
thrilled to be able to have back here on
the show bubba wallace how are you bubba
i'm good how are you i can't believe
it's been that long it has but it feels
like a year doesn't it
it does i would say time flies when
you're having fun but i don't know if
it's been
that fun it's a lot of work but there's
been a lot of work and obviously a lot
has been going on
in the world how are you and your family
everybody good
buddy happy helping everybody's good my
mom is actually uh she just had knee
surgery uh
two weeks ago so she's actually
recovering from that and
recovering well she'll be out for you
know six to eight weeks but
um she's still calling every day so it's
been good okay so what has it been like
racing in a pandemic bubble let's start
with that one
first when it was beginning uh i think
you called in just at the outset
of nascar being the first sport
essentially to return
to live action you led the way in terms
of protocols and things of that nature
we talked
at length about that uh what has it been
like now that uh we're
we're catching up yeah no it's so like
somewhat you know
kind of back to normal obviously we
don't have the fans there
and uh you know that's a huge aspect for
us just because that's what
differentiates us from other sports
just the fan uh engagement the fan
access that they have so
while some fans are allowed back like
was uh for example this weekend of the
coke zero sugar 400
daytona you know limited capacity will
be there in the stands but still
there's not many people that are in uh
there's not there's nobody that's in the
infield so still kind of the ghost town
until
there's still stuff too weird to get
used to uh tough to get used to
and so the racing stuff i think has been
exciting for sure and we've continued to
to try and be competitive and do the
most that we can on the racetrack to
provide the excitement
uh for the fans to watch and especially
when they're in person
yeah i mean you mentioned again the uh
the uh uh coke zero
sugar 400 at daytona it airs at 7 30 p.m
eastern on on
nbc as uh the nascar cup series closes
out its regular season
uh this coming uh this coming weekend so
oh
do you do you notice it i guess when
you're behind the wheel of the car you
just don't even think about the fact
that you're racing
in the manor in the world uh that we're
racing right now
now you definitely notice it for sure um
it's it's something that i
you you don't notice it let me let me
rephrase that you don't notice it as
you're you're racing just because we're
going depends on what we're at 200 miles
an hour so it's kind of hard to notice
anything
right it's all a blur but you you notice
it while you're there
and so that's what uh like pre-race it's
quiet
you know during the anthem the
indication all that stuff is just quiet
and that's when you notice it the most
but as soon as we strap
in it's time to go bubba wallace here on
the rich eisen show
um looking at that i read the uh the
profile on you
on gq uh nascar's unlikely
activist what did you think of that
headline of your of the story
bubba yeah yeah that's uh
you know i accept that you know it kind
of reminds me of what my mom said
that you ever think that you'd become an
activist and i'm like no
not really not at all so it's just uh
you know i don't look at it as an
activist i don't look at it as
as as politics as some would say i look
at it as simply
you know what that's not right and i'm
going to say something about it
hopefully it impacts others
well i mean i guess sometimes people are
are not
uh prepared for the moment or ready for
the moment but the moment has certainly
found you did you seek out any advice on
on what uh on how to
uh handle matters or what to um
how to communicate it bubba
no i just you know for me i hate when i
have
to do interviews and i get talking
points before it
and they're like hey say that i'm like
hey let me do
what i can do and be myself as soon as
it becomes scripted then i'm like
everybody else you know i hate i hate
things that are scripted
and so for me um
i say what's on the heart and i'll have
amanda
or my my manager kind of look over it
and then proofread it and make sure i
didn't say anything that was
crazy and i want to show my k through
11 and a half education nice yeah sounds
smart
right um so yeah i think uh i think
um you know for me it's just all about
coming from the heart
but making sure i come off in the right
way yeah you're referring to amanda
carter your your girlfriend
um who's also featured in the article
as well look i i guess that's why you're
so great at racing is that it's
um you know that's unscripted so you
like being unscripted
um how how have
uh you been received um um
at racetracks since you have become more
prominent in this area bubba
oh yeah i'm definitely not a fan
favorite anymore
um all-star raids people loved
the booze when my name was called and
they loved when
i was crashed out there on lap 15.
um and then what was it at
uh i think daytona there was the booze
so hey it's all good they're uh
my name sparks some sort of reaction
inside them
whether it's good or bad they're saying
something so i'm good with it but why is
that
bubba what why why would that be and i i
i asked that open-ended okay and i i i
can kind of
um you know uh gather what you might say
but i just want to put that in front of
you
yeah why they would do yeah i mean why
right
like why do you think that is is it the
is it the
the fact that the confederate flag is no
longer allowed at nascar and they
associate that with you
and your activism is it what do you
think it is is it because of
the way the the door handle um
incident went down for the lack of
better phrase could it be the tweet from
the president
i mean what what is it it's for sure
the news incident uh well it might be
some of confederate flag
so be it uh everybody still wants to
hang on to the narrative that
i that i want for one went and
hung the news myself uh oh i'm sorry i
mean the door handle
right um and and then recorded it myself
just to
get the fame and fortune out of it so
that's the
that's the narrative that people are
continuing to hang on to and you know
while the facts are have been out there
um and even the president knew the facts
two weeks before
uh he wanted to send a tweet about it uh
people still hang on to that
and that's that's their problem not mine
um and you know
there's there's articles going around
there saying that i've called every
nascar fan who's racist
and and and that's not the truth i would
simply ask
uh what do you what what do i have to
say to those fans those nascar fans that
think
that this is all hoax and all a joke
and to those nascar fans that think that
was a joke
and i said yes their job can deliver
hate you know they're they're not going
to see
my side of it they don't want to see my
side of it but somehow that got turned
into
every nascar fan the racist and and hey
you know what i could sit here all day
and and try to defend myself
and it just wouldn't go anywhere no i i
know and i just
prefer to use this platform to enlighten
um and for those who don't know uh david
crops who was a
mechanic for richard penny motorsports
he was the one who noticed
the news uh or the the the the handle
that was fashioned as a news
that had apparently been fashioned as
such prior to even
you being assigned that garage for for
some time before
but that was what was surmised after it
was brought up by
david and your and and part of your team
to nascar who handled it the way they
handled it before you even knew anything
about it
correct yeah but hey you know what
you've already put my name on your
program
but people are not going to listen so
that that whole statement there just
went nowhere
it went to the people that already knew
the facts
well i hope i hope otherwise you know
and um but
uh you know i i certainly hope otherwise
because i think what you have to say and
the way that you are saying it is very
important
um in this absolutely i'm with you in
this day and age and
into that just i guess to put um uh if
you will
a uh a button on this portion of our
conversation do you have anything you
want to say about jacob blake the uh
the gentleman in the state of wisconsin
who was shot in the back
um several times uh by police um
who is in the hospital right now yeah
that was
you know luckily and and thank god that
you know i believe he's in stable
condition and hope
uh that he pulls through um
i think you know being able to watch
that and see all that and be exposed to
it is unfortunate
um and and and the thing that really
makes me mad and gets under my skin is
the people that try to justify
what went down uh being shot in the back
is just like sucker punching somebody
you know out at a movie like for you
know and it's like
you know there's two sides yeah you know
they were telling him to stop
and he he wasn't complying i i i
understand outside of it
but to shoot somebody seven times in the
back oh you opened the car door he was
reaching for a gun you know
okay so you're still shooting somebody
there's two two police officers
tackling there's 2v1 tackling
you know a shooting leg i don't know so
shooting sent me seven times in the back
like that's just inhumane it's just
tough to watch and and it's just
something that's unfortunate that still
a part of our nation
bubba wallace here uh on the rich eisen
show bubba what about your future
in racing what are you thinking about
right now and
your decisions for the future here yeah
now there's a lot
to uh there's a lot of process you know
obviously we're in the middle of
contract talks right now silly season
and
uh and trying to get everything lined up
for
for 20 21 um so we'll continue to work
on those efforts while
trying to finish off these last 11 races
on the best note possible
bubba thanks the time i know you have to
run i always appreciate our chats
and uh i look forward to our next one
already hopefully it won't be uh
between may 15th and uh august 24th for
the same length as the next
i really appreciate it absolutely my
friend
always a pleasure back at you that's
bubba wallace here on the rich eisen
show
at bubba wallace on both twitter
and instagram